hey what is up welcome to my youtube
channel and i am in a particularly good
mood today
because today is my birthday it is
actually
my 30th birthday today so i can't say
i'm in my 20s anymore
however i'm feeling really really really
happy i've had a fabulous day i'm gonna
have a party this evening
and tomorrow i'm going um paragliding i
think that's what it's called where you
got up in the sky my wife has booked me
so all round fabulous day all round
fabulous last 30 years and i just
thought shall i have a complete day off
or shall i still do a short youtube
video
for my um my followers and i decided to
do the latter
so how dedicated am i you know what for
my dedication
please do me a massive favor on my 30th
birthday doing a video
please do smash the like button that
would really help me out a lot also drop
a comment below
and in this video i wanted to share okay
so i'm 30 years old i've been
in property i bought my first house when
i was 17
so i've almost not quite yet but almost
been in
property for half of my life that is
absolutely crazy um so
what i learned over the years and i was
really reflecting on when i first got
started in property when i first
started making money when i first became
financially free
age 21 which is now nine years ago
can you believe it like what were some
of the things
that i did to become financially free
in the early years of starting out in my
journey
and i've really i've really brought that
down to three things
and those three things i thought i would
share with you wrap it up and share it
in this video
i've also got a gift as well so i've got
a really really
exciting gift to share with you and it's
going to be a free gift and i'm going to
announce this
tomorrow so right now i'm just getting
the final details wrapped up but it's an
incredible prize
it's a present it's a gift from me to
you
okay so by just watching this video you
will be entitled to this gift
and it is honestly something i've been
working on for i was gonna say years
years
months maybe about a year so you're
gonna love that um
so come back tomorrow in fact subscribe
to the channel so you get notified
tomorrow
and then you'll see what the prize what
the gift is tomorrow
so just um down below it'll be subscribe
click that button
turn on the notification bell and then
you'll get the gift tomorrow
so one of the things that i would say
helps me become financially free and the
very first thing is this and this is
almost
contrary to what you might
um think this is contrary to what it um
most of the you know the gurus or the
youtube influencers
um you know even me to a point when you
see me in my range rover
and my ninth house and you know but i
think it's really important
to remember how these people that you
see multi-millionaires how they started
and what they did in the early days and
copy what they did in the early days
not just what they're doing today and
the the first thing that i want to say
out of the three points is
i think it's really really important
that you simplify
your living expenses simplify your
living expenses
what do i mean by that do i mean that
you should live in poverty
do i mean that you should you know not
spoil yourself or have any nice things
absolutely not but what i mean is you
want to get your
your monthly overheads as low as they
can be
to begin with to begin with
so what i would suggest that you do is
you write down get a pen and paper
and your bank statement write down how
much
right now today it currently costs you
to live
okay how much are you spending per month
at the moment now that might be two
thousand three thousand four thousand
pounds a month
and then think okay well how much
could i shrink this by how small
could i get that figure okay now you
might be thinking samuel
get out of here i couldn't get it any
smaller
but one of the things that i realized
was when all throughout the
my late teens and even beginning of
early 20s is
that sometimes you actually can and i
remember my dad saying to me
yeah um oh man oh that i've already you
know i already live a really simple life
i couldn't shrink my
living expenses and then he moved from
england to brazil this was the first
time he moved to brazil which was many
years ago
he now has moved back to brazil but when
he closed his english bank account he
had all these subscriptions
you know he had a dating agency
subscription
he was now married but this little thing
coming out his bank every single month
um gym memberships that you might not be
going to i just spoke to my friend
yesterday who said he's been paying for
his gym membership all throughout the
lockdown
uh accidentally now if he'd have been
supporting the gym that would have been
a different thing
but it was just an expense that he'd
forgotten about so go through your
standing orders go through your direct
debits and think
how small can i shrink my living
expenses
you know do i really necessarily need
that second car do i really necessarily
need to be having
you know uh shopping at waitrose when i
could be shopping
maybe at asda you know and again this
sounds contrary to what you might expect
me to teach
but this is what i did now i shrunk my
living expenses
to as low as i possibly could and then
once you've done that
that is the figure that you need to earn
in passive
income to become financially free so
that's the first
step to financial freedom it's working
out
how simple could you live your life and
then
ingraining that figure in your brain and
setting out to earn that figure in
passive income which we'll come back to
later
so that's the first step step number two
is managing your money
and again this might sound like oh
thanks tammy all great management but
it's really really really important that
you do this and i've got a little method
that i use for managing money which i'll
share with you on this video
and what i mean by managing money is
paying yourself
first most people what they do is they
get paid
they get their salary their you know two
thousand pound salary or whatever it
might be
and then they quickly pay their bills
so they pay the the uh electric bill
they pay the gas
man they pay the um the mortgage or the
ram
they pay their bills and then they save
what's left and how much is usually left
nothing right or a little bit and then
they save it and
then the following month it blows and
sometimes people say to me
you know ah if only i was earning a
little bit more money
and then i'd be able to save more money
and the truth is
that if they were to earn more money
miraculously that cost of
the cost of living would just go up and
and same story so
how do you get around this problem of
just spending everything that you earn
and the answer is you pay yourself first
and you manage your money properly
so i remember going to a a conference
called millionaire mind intensive a very
very
long time ago with a guy called half
ecker and he taught something around
money management
it was a fabulous system and i remember
thinking that is awesome
i am gonna do that i'm so gonna do that
and i got home
and didn't do it and then the next year
i went back to the same conference
and i heard the same teaching and i was
like oh i'm gonna do that and i guess
what i went home
and didn't do it i went back to the same
conference
true story okay three years later and i
remember going
and i heard it guess just guess what i
said guess what i said when i heard the
same
same money management pay yourself first
teaching it i said
i already know that i already know that
i've heard this before but i wasn't
doing
it so the lesson is if you're not
doing it you don't know it so whilst
this might sound really basic
i would just highly suggest that you
just go and do it it was only when i
said oh i already know that and then and
then the trainer on stage said oh by the
way
if you say i already know that that's
the most dangerous thing to say unless
you're doing it you don't know
oh my i felt so convicted and then i
thought you know what i'm actually gonna
do it i went home and i did it and what
i did was
i set up um i set up separate bank
accounts so i actually set up six bank
accounts
one was my necessities back
one was my play bank one was my
education
bank one was my gift
bank one was my investment
bank and the sixth was my savings bank
they might think
oh man i could be doing with six bank
accounts that is ridiculous
um they don't need to be separate bank
accounts from different banks you don't
know nat
west and the halifax and the lloyds what
you can do is you can just have
different e-servers
now what you're going to do is when you
get paid your wage say your 2 000 pound
wage
you're going to immediately split it up
into the different bank accounts
so your necessities you might put 50
of your wage into your necessities back
which would be 1 000 pounds
and then you're going to put 10 of your
wage in all the other accounts
10 into your give account 10 into your
play
account 10 into your um investment
account
and what will happen when you do that is
you will be in control of your finances
now there's so many reasons why you
could come
up with excuses why not to do this you
might think
i couldn't live off 50 even if you
couldn't live on 50
if you just manage your money but change
the percentages i remember teaching this
at one of the property investors crash
courses
and there was a guy called carl in the
audience and carl had
you know not much money uh he was quite
miserable
he had his arms folded and it turned out
i didn't know this but carl at the time
was upset with me for suggesting that he
put 50
of his um salary aside for necessities
and then breaking the other up
to put into investments and give because
he was he was upset because he was
thinking
right now i'm already spending more than
i'm earning
i'm earning 1200 pounds a month as a
cleaner
and my outgoings on necessities are 1250
pounds
i've got no money to give i've got no
money to invest so he was quite upset
with the teachings he thought he sounded
like
some rich person teaching this however
you know by the end of the course he
decided that he would do it a little bit
differently
and he decided that he would put 94
but 95 of his money aside from
necessities
and they just put one percent into gift
one percent into one percent
he shrunk his living expenses slightly a
bit lower
and and what happened was he he regained
control of his finances
i met him about three years later and
guess what he was financially free
just because he started paying himself
first and we gained control of his
finances so i could talk about money
management
and this whole set up in the system um
for for literally hours and hours and
hours but what i'll say is
take control of your finances if you if
you're naturally a spender
um or if you're naturally a hoarder and
saver
just manage your finances this way and
you'll find yourself really really
getting in control and some people want
more money
i need more money i need to make more
money you don't need more money what you
need is you need to manage the money
that you've got
the bible says when you're faithful with
a little
then you'll be given more so manage your
finances so the first thing is simplify
your living expenses second is to manage
your finances
and then the third thing that i want to
say is a step towards financial freedom
is to think in terms of passive income
rather than active income most people
just want more money
what you need is you need to be trying
to create passive income streams passive
income streams
such as book royalties affiliate links
mark affiliate marketing links stocks
and shares and
investments and my favorite one of
course property investment
how many times do you need to keep
buying the property before it will stop
giving you rent
and the answer is just once you don't
need to buy ever again once you buy a
property it will give you rent forever
and ever
and the property will outlive you and it
will appreciate in value over time
which has been historically proven so
think in terms of
passive income because then what will
happen is when your passive
income you're putting aside a little bit
of money for investments every month
and then you're going to invest that
money into something that's going to
give you your passive
income and then you'll have the active
salary which might be 2 000
a month but then you'll have your
passive income which is
500 a month then the percentages
you'll start getting a little bit more
you have to pay up a little bit more and
slowly the passive income
will replace the active income which
will mean you then are financially free
so those are just three steps to become
financially free there's so much more i
could say there's so much more i want to
say
subscribe to the channel for more top
tips i'm gonna go and enjoy
continuing to celebrate my 30th birthday
don't forget to turn on the notification
bell
because tomorrow i'm going to be giving
away something amazing to
every single one of my subscribers i
just want to say massive thank you for
being
a follower a subscriber a contributor to
my channel i've been running now for
many many years
um look forward to seeing you tomorrow
have a wonderful wonderful evening and
god bless